Hi, I'm Deadpool.
The other jolly guy in a red suit with a lap
was sitting on here to tell you.
Happy holidays.
So sit back, hold on. Your ornaments.
Guzzle a little eggnog.
At least that looks like eggnog.
And prepare yourself
because it's time for Saint Wade to put the win
in winter wonderland.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
We just learned about more characters
coming back for Deadpool 3
and some of the recent changes they made to the movie
since the strikes delayed everything,
allowing Ryan Reynolds, the Marvel people
just time to tune some things up in the movie.
So we'll break it all down.
It is going to be crazy
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
because they're filming right now.
We will get some more footage for Deadpool
three real soon.
we're also still doing that giveaway for the Disney
plus Blu rays for Loki Wandavision The Mandalorian.
They're finally giving away Blu rays for all the Disney
Plus series All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just let me know
what you want them to do with X-Men
going forward in Marvel, the field is wide open.
Like they can literally do anything
because it will be the first time that they've done
anything in the MCU with them.
but you probably saw recently the Deadpool
three started filming again
just before the Thanksgiving holiday.
Recently,
They finished most of the movie before the strikes,
but there was still a little bit of filming left to do.
Marvel made some big changes to all the movies
coming out next year, not just Deadpool,
largely because of the strikes, though,
and because of those delays.
Now, Deadpool three is like the only MCU Marvel movie
coming out next year.
There's still a couple of Sony Spider-Man
spinoff movies coming out, like the Spider-Man
Madam Web movie,
which is kind of like morbius for women.
literally the same people that wrote
the Morbius movie wrote them at a Web movie,
which I think is kind of funny.
I cannot wait for all the memes.
its web in time.
Also, the Kraven movie coming out next year too.
It's kraven time. But.
There are a bunch of bigger TV shows
that they're going to be releasing
next year, like X-Men 97 episodes cannot wait for that.
Very apropos to because we're talking about Deadpool
three and all the X-Men stuff happening during that.
it's been 84 years since we've seen X-Men,
the Animated Series.
I've already done a bunch of videos
about some of the cameos, the plot of Deadpool three.
But now we've learned that supposedly x 23, Daphne Keen
is coming back as an older version of the character,
and if you predicted that they'd bring her back,
I think a lot of people did pat yourself on the back.
is there like a pretty slam dunk
to bring her back at some point
just because she hit so hard during the Logan movie?
if it wasn't going to be Deadpool 3,
they probably would have brought her back in.
Something else.
James Mangold,
who did the Logan movie, was even developing
an X-23 movie when Disney bought Fox.
this is her talking about coming back as the character.
Recently, though.
we are officially getting mutants in our mainline MCU.
And the obvious question has been if he's coming over
to play with Ryan and the rest of the gang.
Will you perhaps join them at some point in some way?
Is that something that would appeal to you?
Would you prefer to be in full mainline Marvel
or would you
rather be in Deadpool
poking Ryan Reynolds with a sharp stick?
Look, I'll do anything because I love playing Laura.
I anything to play her again.
So clearly she was just waiting for them to ask her
to come back and for them to work out a deal.
Apparently that just happened.
the next big question I'm sure a lot of you have is
what about the Logan movie, Hugh Jackman?
Ryan Riddle said
very specifically they weren't de canonizing Logan
or going to touch the plot of that movie at all.
So what is the deal with X 23 coming back?
for example, how is Wolverine alive? Yeah.
After Logan, Logan takes place in 2029.
Totally separate thing.
Logan died in Logan. Not touching that.
What actually happens in our film
is the easiest explanation for that.
These is way around
that logic Problem is the older version of x
23 would just be coming from another universe
if it wasn't clear.
As far as we know, the vast majority
of all those classic versions of the X-Men
that are coming back will be from outside
the main X-Men universe, not inside the main universe.
the Logan movie is meant to be canon
to the main X-Men universe,
but it's from like the distance future of that universe
as far as I know, Deadpool himself.
Maybe his version of Vanessa
will be the only characters from the main X-Men
universe that are coming back
or going to be in the MCU in the future.
it if he didn't realize they kind of
did this during Deadpool two,
Deadpool is canon to the main X-Men universe.
That's why they had that X-Men cameo scene with him
almost seeing the characters.
It was a bit of a joke about it.
First Class is canon to the original classic X-Men.
Movies like Those are just the younger versions
of those actors.
the whole idea is the days of future past
sort of united those X-Men franchises
or the first class movies or canonically
just the younger versions of all the classic versions.
Deadpool
also joked about this during the first Deadpool movie.
So many timelines, so confusing
beginning of Deadpool three,
Deadpool is still using cable's time travel device.
He's visiting other universes.
That's how he runs into this version of Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine, who's wearing a version
of the classic yellow suit.
This one's a little bit
more like the astonishing X-Men version of the suit,
the whole reason it has sleeves,
though, is because he had a skin cancer issue recently.
They wanted to cover his arms
during their outdoor shoots just to avoid making things
worse for him so he might lose the sleeves later
in the movie, in some indoor scenes.
and yes, he will have a version of the helmet
to go with the suit.
He just wasn't wearing it in the scenes that we got
a look at recently that were happening outdoors.
they did not say whether or not
this new version of x-23 will come
from the same universe that this Wolverine comes from,
or just like a completely different one.
But part of the plot of the movie will revolve around
Deadpool traveling through the multiverse
to find the perfect version of Wolverine,
eventually coming to the realization
that Hugh Jackman's version, like this
version, is the perfect Wolverine.
that's just the movie clowning On the fact
that the X-Men are about to be recast by Kevin Foggy
for the new upcoming X-Men movies in the new MCU movies
in general, like the Deadpool movie will be saying,
no, these versions are the perfect version
is there's no way you could recast them.
Like Hugh
Jackman will always be the best version of Wolverine.
very tongue in cheek.
Them all winking from behind the camera.
But if it wasn't clear Ryan Reynolds will continue
to play the Deadpool character going forward
in all the future Marvel movies.
Hugh Jackman is just coming back for Deadpool
three in Secret Wars.
like a lot of the classic X-Men
characters are just coming back for Deadpool three
because it's sort of like a Spider-Man
No Way Home for the X-Men movies like Deadpool
No Way Home or X-Men
No Way Home
I think part of the idea is that they're using Deadpool
3 just to see how the movie does.
And if people really like those classic X-Men
characters coming back,
more of them will come back during Secret Wars.
But if it doesn't do really, really well,
they'll just pull back a little bit on that.
During Secret Wars.
So early theory right now
is that Deadpool just runs into a version of X-23.
Daphne Keen here when he's hopping through universes
looking for the best version of Wolverine.
He just has some jokes about her
being a female Wolverine
because she's literally a female clone of him.
Canonically.
that's basically how they avoid
touching the plot of the Logan movie
or messing with the events of the previous X-Men
movies.
That's all still canon to that main X-Men universe.
sort of the way that Tobey Maguire Spider-Man came back
during Spider-Man, No Way Home.
He'll come back during Secret Wars.
Andrew Garfield did the same thing,
but they're not messing with the continuity
of the universes that they came from.
they're not touching the plot
of their Spider-Man movies respectively.
now the next question. I know.
Just because x 23 might be coming back in Deadpool
three, I don't know if that means
she's also coming back in Avengers Secret Wars.
Daphne Keen is currently working on the Star Wars
acolyte TV show that might run multiple seasons.
She's got other movies, other shows she'll be filming,
so she seems pretty busy.
I'm not going to hold my breath for Secret Wars.
I believe she's going to be playing a Jedi character
during Star Wars acolyte.
I've already done a trailer video for that,
so I'll link it.
Blown the description,
but we're not going to see that for a while.
and there's already going to be a billion characters
in secret wars.
So I'd be totally cool if she's not in secret wars.
Going back
A couple of years, though, before Disney bought Barks,
Marvel got all its characters back.
Originally, Fox had totally different plans
for the future of their Marvel X-Men movies.
Obviously they had the Fantastic Four movies too,
but this is mostly just about the X-Men movies,
Ryan Reynolds
revealed that he was going to make a Deadpool three,
but it would have been a Deadpool
Wolverine Road trip like midnight Run it.
Even though they're kind of doing that
for this MCU version of Deadpool three,
the Fox version, that would have been a way
smaller movie.
It wouldn't have involved the multiverse
and it wouldn't really involved any time travel either.
this MCU version is more like Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe
because so much of it is leaning up to time runs out.
Storylines from the comics setting up secret wars.
it's kind of like a giant mini
Avengers movie with X-Men characters.
Mosley
I mentioned earlier that Fox was also developing an X
23 solo movie
that would have been a sequel to the Logan movie.
This is James Mangold talking a little bit about it.
It sounds like he got pretty close, but they didn't
quite finish the script before Disney bought Fox.
It put the kibosh on all those X-Men movies
that Fox had been planning before the buyout.
I started working on a story
and but I don't think of that as a universe.
I just loved the character
and I thought, Daphne just like Ryan Reynolds
original version of Deadpool three that X 23 solo movie
wouldn't have involved any time travel or multiverse
or any of that kind of stuff.
It would have been more in the tone of the Logan movie,
supposedly during Deadpool three, we'll see
those classic X-Men coming back as more comic book
looking versions of the characters,
all just popping on screen just a little bit more,
more classic comic book costumes, battling it out
with part of the movie, making fun of Avengers Endgame,
as you might have expected.
Like, of course,
they're going to be clowning on all the Marvel movies.
but I think specifically they referenced them
clowning on the portals
scene, like Deadpool gets his own Avengers
assemble kind of moment,
but it's a bunch of variance,
a bunch of X-Men related characters doing it
if you think about it, Avengers
Endgame was such a big movie it earned so much money.
Of course, there would be a ton of parodies.
I mean, probably the best parody of Marvel
and DC movies recently, though, has been the Boys
series just in general,
particularly their Dawn of the Seven movie,
which was meant to be both a parody of the Justice
League movie and Avengers Endgame.
they even had Charlize Theron
playing a version of Stormfront doing it,
and she was in Doctor Strange two is crazy
that those two things came out around the same time
There are a couple moments
during that Dawn of the Seven movie
that were parodies of moments during Avengers Endgame,
but the biggest one was The Girls Get It Done scene,
which was meant to parody the F-word scene.
Maybe Deadpool will have his own girls get It Done
type of scene, which is a bunch of Deadpool variants.
Bryan Reynolds even teased dog poo here like he posted.
This is in the actual movie looking like this.
So that means that at least part of the Deadpool
core will be in the movie.
if you're not a big comic book reader,
they're basically just a bunch of Deadpool variants
from different universes.
there is a bunch of big X-Men related stuff happening
really soon.
We'll get X-Men 97 episodes early next year,
probably after the Echo episodes after.
What if season 2
Mr. Sinister is supposed to be the main villain of this
first new season?
in. It's basically meant to feel like X-Men,
the animated series Season six,
which is way better Artwork
tuned up with modern technology
I just did a trailer video for that,
so I'll link it at the end of this.
What if season two episodes
will start in a couple of weeks
I'll be doing episode videos for that too, so be sure
to enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for my X-Men 97 trailer video
and click here for my What If Season 2 trailer video
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!